kalyna good merci d'avoir accepté cette
entrevue pour radio canada international
comment allez vous très bien merci
et vous ça va très bien on essaie de
nouvelles manières de communiquer de
nouvelles manières de fonctionner donc
voilà tout le monde recommence
un fait est resté des choses donc merci
quand même d'avoir accepté ministres le
secrétaire général de l'onu a récemment
rappelé iq et 310 millions d'élèves près
de la moitié du total mondial compte sur
l'école pour se nourrir chaque jour et
comme la grande majorité de ces enfants
ne vont pas à l'école en ce moment ne
vont pas à l'école en ce moment la
malnutrition horaires d'importantes
conséquences c'est ce qu'il aime
secrétaire de l'onu
perez a dit il a aussi dit que même
avant la pandémie les taux mondiaux de
malnutrition et des retards de
croissance chez les enfants étaient
inacceptables
mais ce que le canada a récemment
convoqué à une réunion du groupe d'amis
pour la sécurité alimentaire à l'onu
pour essayer de trouver des manières
d'atténuer ces faits qui pourraient
avoir la pandémie chez les enfants est
en général et la population d'aller à
l'est dans les pays les plus pauvres du
monde donc dites nous quelles étaient
les conclusions de cette réunion qui a
eu lieu la semaine dernière un bien sûr
mais effectivement c'est tout à fait une
situation vraiment préoccupante
comme vous avez mentionné 370 millions
d'élèves
elle compte sur le programme alimentaire
a pour leur nature dans leur école et
maintenant il ya 82 % à des élèves qui
ne ce qu'ils ne vont pas à l'école dans
le monde 80 2% mais le canada travaille
avec le programme
d'alimentation mondiale a pour assurer
qu'il y à des alternatives pour accéder
à une nourriture par exemple nous avons
a fourni 13 points 5 millions de dollars
1 100 membres de notre réponse a occupé
de 19 ans seulement pour le programme
alimentaire mondial a le programme a le
pam est en train de travailler avec les
gouvernements nationaux pour avoir des
points de distribution pour assurer
qu'il y à toujours à une accès à la
nourriture a alors c'est une des choses
qui font à est-ce que c'est suffisant ah
c'est une question mais sur les cinq
sens c'est quelque chose à qu'ils font
pour assurer que les élèves qui
normalement auraient accès à la
nourriture pour les écoles au top
alternative pour avoir accès à la
nourriture comme vous avez mentionné le
vendredi matin et j'ai ajouté j'ai fait
partie du nahd d'une réunion
extraordinaire à haut niveau à l'onu sur
ce thème là et à ce que nous avons et en
être écoutés c'est que vraiment c'est
une des enjeux les plus importants
maintenant dans le monde et c'est un des
prairies priorités du canada
le pam à nourrice actuellement à 100
millions de personnes annuellement alors
le canada travaille avec nous allier
avec nos partenaires car tout moment
pour assurer qu'il y a toujours accès à
des chaînes de nourriture à des
démarches et pour assurer qu'il ya
toujours le commerce et nous appuyons
aussi travaillant avec des auteurs pays
pour assurer qu'ils mentent qu'il
maintient ouvert leurs marchés qu'ils ne
prennent pas des mesures initiales he is
all in is all in history channel vous
rassurer que que toujours à illies à
d'accès à la nourriture mais c'est une
des choses les plus importants d'où le
monde droit à m le sib parce que les
conséquences peuvent être
des vestes en s'ils ne sont pas engagés
directement dans la sécurité à
l'écriture vous le savez justement ma
prochaine question était concernant la
communauté de la coopération
internationales particulièrement celles
du canada qui est en première ligne de
la réponse mondiale la pente des mines
de lakovic 19 et comme elle a été dans
plusieurs sortes pandémie et dans
plusieurs autres crises à travers le
monde
quel support particulièrement recevront
les travailleurs humanitaires
canadiennes du gouvernement du canada
bon il y avait beaucoup de travailleurs
humanitaires qui étaient sur le terrain
quelques organisations décidé de le
retourner à la maison
pour preuve pour l'heure protégé les
autres sont déjà là et nous travaillons
avec les organisations des ong
internationales pour les appuyer mais
aussi il ya beaucoup de canadiens qui
travaillent avec l'eau nous les autres
stations internationales qui sont sur le
terrain
nous sommes en train de les écouter le
travail avec coeur et d'essayer de les
appuyer tant que techniquement apport
les les préoccupations qui savait parler
de la deûle entrée des denrées de
l'entrée des travailleurs humanitaires a
aussi mais à part la sécurité
alimentaire et et l'entrée de ceux
travaillant là il y a il y à d'autres
occupations pour les canada à l'étranger
en ce moment dans le cadre de cette
pandémie
bien sûr mais bon premièrement de la
priorité c'est la crise de santé etc
assurer que les autres pays en les
capacités de faire les tests de assuré
qu'ils ont de l'équipement de personnel
de les protéger pour les travailleurs et
travailleuses de premières viennent à
qui ont besoin à de la voir si c'est la
même crise que nous avons ici au canada
pour nos travailleurs dans le système de
santé
mais c'est quand même a pu expira dans
les pays de développement parce qu'ils
n'ont
non à l'accès à cette équipe équipant
mais aussi c'est d'assurer à une
préoccupation des des secondaires et
tertiaires effet de santé alors on sait
que des campagnes de la fin de trop bio
par exemple en bus est à flux tendus
durant cette campagne alors c'est il ya
une préoccupation que d autres maladies
infectueuses pourrait avoir à une
kambakhsh pour de si tôt pour dire de
comme ci comme ça à prendre dans cette
pandémie était unique une grande
préoccupation a de nouveau au canada
aussi le canada a été et est toujours
une idée d'un espace de santé maternelle
à de l'enfance et et des bébés et de
voir qui a toujours un provisionnement
de soins a dans cet acteur la a aussi à
l'accès au droit et services de santé
sexuelle et reproductive c'est aussi une
préoccupation et l'autre préoccupation
pour moi personnellement c'est c'est
l'accès à l'éducation est la
continuation des études j'ai mentionné
82 points 5 % des élèves actuellement
dans le monde vont pas à l'école
c'est sans précédent et on sait que les
élèves en s'articulant défi en situation
vulnérable
à quand des choses retourne à la ce qui
va le nouveau normal il ya eu une grand
risque que ces élèves à retirer devant
les filles ne retourne pas ne retournera
pas à l'école herrina gaulle le canada
appuyer rapidement l'appel du secrétaire
des nations unies pour un cessez le feu
mondial pendant la pandémie à quelques
préoccupations réponse cette posture
particulièrement
oui c'était vraiment important pour le
canada depuis cet appel à ses soeurs
nous savons que dans beaucoup de
situations de conflit les les systèmes
de santé on était vraiment à son ne sont
pas adéquats et particulièrement au
yémen et en syrie où le système de santé
était vraiment dévasté 1 pour parler
confie c'est déjà difficile à recevoir
des soins de santé
on sait aussi que les gens sont déjà
dans une situation extrêmement
vulnérable à cran ils vivent comme les
vivent dans une situation de conflit et
la pandémie a pourrait les mettre dans
une situation doublement vulnérable
alors le canada appuie totalement cet
appel du secrétaire général pour essayer
de protéger les gens de l'antique la
transmission à de kobe 19 parce qu'on
sait qu'on est dans les situations de
conflits ça pourrait être encore plus
difficile d'isoler les gens qui ont
besoin 6e s'ils sont malades et aussi à
comprenons que c'est déjà extrêmement
difficile à recevoir à des soins de
santé dans ces contextes ministre le
canada a aussi conclu un accord avec
l'arabie saudite dernièrement ou brun
ils ont la possibilité à de nouvelles
ventes d'armes à ce pays
voyez-vous en contradiction entre les
cessez le feu et l'appui au cessez le
feu
et puis 7-7 nouvel accord mais comme
comme été annoncée par son collègue le
ministre champagne le milieu des
affaires étrangères à cet accord c'est
une accord qui a été négocié avec
l'ancien gouvernement conservateur et
s'est pas desserré les nouveaux à
négociation du contrat et que le canada
fait une analyse extensive a pour
assurer que ces armes à n'étaient pas
utilisés pour contredire
pour qui a des infractions sur les
doigts du maine et le canada continuera
de monitorer d'absorber à cramant et en
massant utiliser celui qu il vraiment
elles sont utilisées par par l'arabie
saoudite
et si il y à des questions à des
violations de droits humains à que le
canada ne comprends pas mais que ce
moment là le canada a le confiance que
ce n'est pas le cas
karina gold 7 ministre du développement
international du canada merci beaucoup
pour cette entrevue pour radio canada
international
merci beaucoup à vous